Новий, 2018 рік, рік змінить життя багатох українців
На які зміни чекати - огляд DW
Не встигли українці звикнути до мінімальної зарплатні у 3200 гривень
як вона вже 3723
Щоправда, це до оподаткування
На руки працівники отримають подекуди
на цілу тисячу гривень менше
Урядовці обіцяють протягом року
підняти мінімалку іще на 400 гривень
якщо для цього будуть відповідні
економічні передумови
Стипендії студентам обіцяють підняти до 1700 гривень
«Золотий дощик» чекає на депутатів і посадовців
чиї оклади прив‘язані до мінімалки або прожиткового мінімуму
2018-й змінить життя водіїв
З нового року максимальна дозволена швидкість руху в українських містах
50 км на годину, а не 60, як раніше
Втім, водії можуть і далі
розганятися до 70 кілометрів
не боячись штрафів
Адже межа толерантності
поки залишилась без змін
Новації торкнуться і молодих водіїв
Перші права їм видаватимуть лише на два роки
Якщо за цей час новачок скоїв
не більше двох дрібних порушень
зможе отримати постійні
На українському кордоні з 1 січня – біометричний контроль
В аеропортах та пунктах пропуску
прикордонники братимуть відбитки пальців у громадян 70 держав  «міграційного ризику»
передусім з Африки та Близького Сходу
До них тепер включили й Росію
Як прогнозують у Києві, нововведення
допоможуть у боротьбі з тероризмом
та ускладнять в'їзд в Україну
шпигунам та диверсантам
Новий рік може стати революційним
у вирішенні проблеми сміття в Україні
Адже вже від 1 січня закон
зобов’язує українців сортувати непотріб
а захоронювати можна лише залишок
Щоправда, це лише в теорії
На практиці усе складніше
В Мінекології, приміром, визнають
що жодне місто в Україні зараз не готове до сортування
через катастрофічну нестачу сміттєвих баків
Бракує також сміттєпереробних підприємств
У 2018-му році в Україні стартує медична реформа
Вона передбачає, що кожен українець
має знайти сімейного лікаря
терапевта або педіатра для дитини
і підписати з ним угоду
Звернення до цих фахівців
а також термінові операції та догляд за смертельно хворими пацієнтами
залишаються безкоштовними
Натомість частина послуг стає офіційно платною
Це, передусім, стосується естетичної хірургії
та стоматології
окрім екстрених випадків